Speaker 1: There is a super interesting article
in The New York Times about Tucker Carlson
and journalists and anonymous sources that
I want to look at with you today.
And what's most interesting, there's a few
things that are interesting about this article.
One are the things we learn about Tucker Carlson
specifically, but also what we learn about
this relationship in terms of trading for
access that exists in general, in politics,
but also in the political media space.
So let's jump right into it.
The article in The New York Times called Tucker
Carlson calls journalists animals.
He's also their best source.
And the article by Ben Smith starts last month.
I texted Tucker Carlson to ask him a question
that was on my mind.
Did you get vaccinated?
When was the last time you had sex with your
wife and in what position?
He replied, We can trade intimate details.
Then we argued back and forth about vaccines,
and he ended the conversation with a friendly
invitation to return to his show.
Always a good time.
One question you may be asking if you're a
New York Times reader is why are you exchanging
texts with Tucker Carlson, the Fox News host
who recently described the media at large
as cringing animals who are not worthy of
respect?
And if you're a Tucker Carlson viewer, you
may also be asking, how can the guy who tells
you every night that the media is lying be
texting with the enemy?
The answer is one of Washington's open secrets.
Mr. Carlson, a proud traitor to the elite
political class, spends his time when he's
not denouncing the liberal media trading gossip
with them.
He's the go to guy for sometimes unflattering
stories about Donald Trump and for coverage
of the internal politics of Fox News, not
to mention stories about Carlson himself.
I won't talk here about any off the record
conversations they may have had with him.
But 16 other journalists, none from the Times,
told me on background that he has been, as
three of them put it, a great source in Trump's
Washington.
Tucker Carlson is a primary super secret source.
The media writer and Trump chronicler Michael
Wolff writes in his forthcoming collection
of essays, he explained, I know this because
I know what he has told me and I can track
his exquisite too good not to be true gossip
through unsourced reports and as it often
emerges into the accepted wisdom.
So take away no one is.
We knew it.
But this is confirmation.
Tucker Carlson plays a character on his program.
In the midst of all the anti vaccine stuff,
he's almost certainly been vaccinated, as
has his family, I'm sure in the midst of all
of his attacks on the media and his sort of
kowtowing to this populist stuff that he does.
He is a sort of regular elite insider that
communicates with all these very same people.
Shouldn't surprise us.
We already suspected that article goes on
to say Mr. Carlson was particularly well positioned
to be a source about the Trump administration,
his Fox platform, where in May he had a nightly
average of three million viewers, made him
someone who mattered to Trump, a close follower
of television ratings.
He has a former reporter's eye for detail
and anecdote, and his observations can be
detected in the lurid details of Trump's chaotic
court and Fox's own tumultuous internal politics.
Upcoming book by the reporter Michael Bender
includes a moment in which Carlson sends Trump's
calls to voicemail after the first presidential
debate last fall, when he was criticized for
repeatedly interrupting Joe Biden when Trump
finally reaches.
The book describes verbatim an exchange between
the two men that cast Mr. Carlson in a flattering
light.
Everyone says, I did a good job, Trump tells
Carlson.
I don't know who told you that was good.
Mr. Carlson says it was not good.
Mr. Bender declined to comment on the sourcing
that allowed him to so precisely reconstruct
the conversation between the two men.
Of course, the belief would be, well, the
source is Tucker himself.
The article continues.
Brian Stelter, the host of the CNN show Reliable
Sources, told me, quote, You can see Tucker's
fingerprints all over the hardcover edition
of his 20/20 book Hoax, which excoriates Fox
for amplifying Trump's falsehoods.
He said he couldn't stomach talking to Carlson,
who has grown ever more hard line for the
updated paperback version that was just released.
Carlson was born to a world of insiders and
story shapers and makes no secret of it.
His father was a reporter in L.A. and San
Diego before Reagan appointed him director
of Voice of America.
And the son grew up with a generation of elite
Washington journalists in twenty eighteen.
Tucker said, I've always lived around people
who were wielding authority around the ruling
class.
A former New York Observer media writer, Shridhar
Papou, recalled to me that when he first traveled
to Washington to cover the White House Correspondents
Association dinner in the 2000s, it was Carlson
who asked him, Do you have an invitation to
Tami's?
Referring to the annual brunch for media insiders
cohosted by Tammy Haddad, the well-connected.
Former MSNBC producer.
So here you start to get the sense that not
only is Tucker not the guy waging war on the
so-called elite media, he's actually a guy
trading on his membership in that very group
in his private life.
Surprising?
Not at all.
A couple other interesting things here.
Carlson said he turned against his fellow
elites after the 2008 financial crisis.
His political shift also transformed his long
journeyman's career as a writer, magazine
writer and MSNBC conservative and make them
Fox's leading tribune of the pro Trump masses.
But his decades of Washington relationships
have produced the tiresome conversation among
Carlson's old friends about what he really
stands for, whether he's really a racist or
whether he cynically plays one on TV, who
knows?
And what does it matter anyway?
That's the same analysis of Trump when we've
said, oh, it sort of seems like Trump plays
coy with anti-Semitic stuff.
But his daughter converted to Judaism.
His grandkids are Jewish, his son in law,
et cetera, et cetera.
What you have to remember is that it doesn't
actually matter.
In the end, if Trump placates and coalesces
that very group, it doesn't really matter
what's in his head.
And that is amplified with Tucker Carlson
as well.
And the article points out, as we have, Karlsson's
recent fixations include suggesting the January
6th capital insurrection was a provocation
staged by the FBI and that making children
wear masks is abuse.
Do we know whether that is really Tucker's
view or not?
No, we don't.
I suspect it's not.
But that is something that will remain a question.
So the takeaways are Tucker's just like all
of these other people.
There's really no difference.
He is the very same type of elite that he
decries.
And unfortunately and I don't want to make
this a bigger thing about populism and grifting
in general, but there is a lot of populist
rhetoric that is rhetoric alone, and it is
not actually the beliefs of the individuals
behind it.
And that can apply on the left and the right
on the right.
A lot of the populist rhetoric is a cover
for just the sort of like elite typical dude
like Tucker on the left.
Sometimes the populist rhetoric is cover for
an authoritarian tendency, which we've also
talked about before.
Last thing you know, you might remember Donald
Trump's discussions of anonymous sources,
anonymous sources shouldn't be allowed, Trump
even seemingly misunderstanding that an anonymous
source isn't anonymous to the journalist.
It's typically that the journalist is just
saying, I won't identify you.
It's very interesting that such a notable
figure on the right is such a prominent anonymous
source when he's supposedly part of a movement
that decries the status quo of the media,
which, as fomented by Donald Trump during
his presidency, includes the criticism of
the use of anonymous sources.
So nothing massively surprising in the article.
It confirms a lot of things we suspected,
but very interesting in that our suspicions
seem to have been very much accurate about
Tucker Carlson.